one of the things that really embodies
America to me is the ideal of Freedom
Hunter Thompson said freedom is
something that dies unless it's used
what does freedom mean to you to me
Freedom does not mean you know chaos
and it does not mean Anarchy it means
that it it it it has to be accompanied
by restraint if it's going to
live up to its promise
um and self-restraint what it means is
the capacity for human beings to
um to exercise and to
fulfill their their creative Energies
unrestrained as much as possible by
government so this point the hunter
estas has made is dies unless it's used
if you agree with that yeah I do agree
with that and I think he'd
he was not unique in saying that you
know Thomas Jefferson said that the tree
of Liberty has to be had to be watered
with the blood of each generation and
what he meant by that is that it it's uh
you can't live off we can't live off The
Laurels of the American Revolution
that you know we had a group we had a
generation where between 25 000 and 70
000 Americans died they gave their lives
they gave their livelihoods they gave
their
status they gave their property and they
put it all on the line to give us our
Bill of Rights and that but those Bill
of Rights the moment that we signed them
there were forces within our society
um that began trying to chip away at
them and that you know what happens in
every generation and it is the
obligation of every generation
to safeguard and protect those freedoms
the blood of each generation